everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're gonna be
going over the adelaide counter gambit
if you're not familiar it is a counter
gambit to the Kings game it one of my
favorite openings as whites so what
better video to make than how to counter
my favorite game it the King's gambit if
you're not familiar starts out with E 4
E 5 and then f4 saying go ahead and take
my pawn here but black does not have to
take that and if you go down the Kings
gambit declined lines the more popular
line is Knight to c6 yeah I'm gonna go
ahead and protect this pawn right here
but I'm just not gonna take this pawn
maybe they prefer this line or maybe
they just don't know what you're up to
and they don't trust you and so they
play Knight to c6 Knight to f3 doesn't
matter if they take or they don't take
here on f4 Knight to f3 is an extremely
common move for whites what I usually
will recommend to people playing the
Kings gambit and this is where the a
delayed counter gambit comes in most
people are gonna be playing at d6 but
that's not fun the adlet counter gambit
is fun and that is f5 it's kind of in
this weird spot of who's gonna make a
move first
how does white correctly respond how
does black have a strong attack here and
black has a very very good game here so
this is why I like this if you're gonna
be playing gambits I think it's always
good to have some fun especially if you
can have a very strong a game so we'll
go ahead and get into some of the main
lines that you will see now what they
should be doing is taking here on f5
I'll show the mistakes they can make if
they don't take here but the main line
would be to take with their pawn and
then you're gonna push forward with E
for attacking there tonight now they
have lots of options they can move with
their Knights one would be to bring the
knight here to g5 attacking the pawn on
e4
now as black we would like to just play
our pot up here to d5 defending this
pawn having a good central control of
the board
but d5 is going to lose too
Queen g5 no way to really stop this if
you play your pawn here the pawns gonna
recapture don't just want to recapture
with your pawn then you lose your rook
here if your knight comes up here to
take the Queen they could push down this
is a discovered attack now the Queen's
attacking yes they can take your queen
but they can just take your rook here
and get that Queen back there's just no
good way for black to really respond
here so because of that although we'd
like to play d5 here that's not gonna be
the optimal move instead gonna be
playing Knight to f6 now there's a few
places they could come from here one is
Knight c3 simple they'll move attacking
this central pawn here on e4 and from
here the move
d5 we do want to control the center of
the board once they've moved their pawn
off this efile we now control the center
with our two pawns they're not gonna be
controlling the center with their deep
on that although they could try to push
maybe d3 trying to break up the center
here once we've moved d5 this does open
up the door for the bishop to get
involved particularly the taking this
material here on f5 so that's exactly
what we are gonna do same thing is if
they were to push further maybe d4 not
looking to take right here with on
passant and then maybe they recapture
with their bishop they're starting to
control the center we've given up our
epon that's not the game we're trying to
play here instead so yeah go ahead and
take that right here I'm gonna take with
my bishop on f5 really still controlling
the center of the board now another
option is once we control the center
they try to control the King side of the
board they're not gonna cast on the King
side that's that's already done and gone
here so they may try G for this defends
that pawn on f5 that we're attacking
with our bishop right here if that's the
case I would just start chipping away at
their their pieces so h6 attacking their
knight where does the knight really move
there's not a lot of great squares maybe
comes here to e6 since he has an outpost
we could exchange right here if he does
that pawn takes right here that's
completely fine we could always put
forward if we want to that is an option
that we have just d4 and now where do
they really move
that's excellent now we're tacking the
Knights here and if the knight comes
back to e - okay well great now that's
blocking the Queen from defending this
pawn on g4 we can take freely with our
knight right here if instead the knight
comes to b5 okay well now the pawn can
come to a6
now you force the knight back here to a3
and now we have lots of different
options we can get our queen involved in
to the board we can get our Bishop
involved so Bishop to d6 makes a lot of
sense just attacking more material here
and then later on we can always get this
pawn back if we want to so lots of
attacking lines that black has once we
just play that d5 move early on now
let's say they don't play Knight to c3
maybe they initially come out the gates
and they want to break up the center of
the board d3
I'd still play d5 controlling the center
opening up for a bishop to get involved
into the game is gonna be extremely key
now if they want to play Knight to c3
similar move order as we've seen before
Bishop takes on f5 same setup now if
they decide yeah I'm gonna go and take
this material right here unfortunately
you do have to take many times we'll try
to recommend a move so you don't have to
exchange Queens on the board but in this
case you really do need to and you also
need to take with your Knights if you do
take with your King just be prepared
they are going to fork you and win your
rook so don't like having to bring the
knight back since we just developed it
here but Knight to d8 is going to be the
move right here instead of d3 if they
were to start with d4 this is another
spot where I recommend not playing on
passant and ambasada if you're not
familiar you have one move in one move
only to take here on d3 it's a diagonal
but this is a legal move once they take
it with their Bishop they're really
controlling the center think about how
much different this board state is
if we let that go don't um pissant here
and then just play d5 controlling the
center attacking with our Bishop right
here and then where do they go from here
so a very strong set up from black now
we'll come back to this position right
here after we push forward on e4 they
also have the option to bring their
Knight to e5 this is an outpost here
instead of attacking the pawn on e4 they
could say I'm not even gonna worry about
that I'm gonna attack this knight on c6
and just try to be a nuisance in the
center of the board from here I would
play Knight f6 for the same reasons that
we talked about the Queen coming down to
h5 is going to be detrimental to our
game we're just going to lose too much
material so after Knight to f6 well now
they have a couple options maybe they
play d4 okay now I'd play d6 you're more
worried about kicking this not a way
then you are controlling the center of
the board since the pawns not under
attack you don't need to defend it as
much with d5 both of these moves are
opening up before your Bishop you get
involved so d6 is gonna be completely
fine does force the knight to move here
I mean you could always play Bishop down
to b5 but more than likely the knight is
gonna move it could capture here that's
completely fine you're just gonna
recapture maybe Knight to c3 here but
then Bishop takes on f5 if you have a
really strong center of the board if
instead they don't want to capture maybe
they come back to c4 you're still the
same thing gonna take your Bishop here
on f5 have a very strong game now if we
come back they also have the option
instead of d4 to still control this King
side of the board with their pawns and
after g4 little tricky move here there
was a variation earlier that you could
have used it on but I prefer the options
that I went over here but if they play
g4 many people will do this I recommend
h5 and all it looks weird if you're
playing in person you can always move
and then be like dang it because if they
take with their pawn maybe look like a
mistake you're just giving up free
material but you're actually gonna have
a dominating board presence after Queen
take or Queen to h4 check there's no
real good squares to move here King to
II - and then Queen takes King where
does it really go from here maybe it
comes back to e one Queen h4 check King
comes up here Bishop to c5 threatening
the Queen to f2 checkmate
not a lot of great squares maybe d4
makes sense but then the knight takes
here things are getting extremely bad no
good way to stop this King D - Queen
takes f4 you you get the picture doesn't
really matter where they go you're gonna
have a very good game some players will
choose not to move their knight in that
case they may play Queen e2 not really
the best move it does block off their
light square bishop for me getting
involved into the game but it says yeah
you're attacking my knight I'm gonna go
ahead and attack pin down your pawn to
the King I wouldn't worry too much about
it the pawn is under attack so in this
case I would recommend d5 we're usually
playing it up this far if the pawn is
under attack might still under attack
don't really matter where they move
we're still threatening to take this
pawn here on f5 so Knight to e5 sure
bishops going to take right here is just
not the strongest move from white so you
don't see it too often and now how does
white really continue if if they want to
take the knight that's that's fine black
has a really strong center they can get
their dark square Bishop mom's of the
game Knight to f6 here why it's gonna
have to move his Queen just to get his
Bishop involved into the game this pawn
right here on f4 it's kind of all by him
lonesome so it's just not the best move
at all now if we come back instead of
actually taking with the pawn here to f5
another option they have is to take with
their pawn to e5 this is gonna be a huge
mistake but some people look at in there
like I just have no idea how to take
here I felt like I should take something
so they take towards the center of the
board which many times that's how you've
heard to capture not really how you want
to be doing it in this spot mostly
because after we take their pawn they're
under attack and there's no good squares
for the night and you could kind of look
at all the different options all of
these squares are
both attacked by the black queen you
don't want to bring it over here to d4
just falls to the knight here so it's
gonna come back to g1 not the best spot
you want and they takes on e5
maybe Knight c3 development Knight to f6
here all of a sudden black is up and
material here and the counter game but
trying to give up material and they just
have a much better board state so this
is going to be very very good for black
they also don't have to take either
these pawns there's a couple moves that
you could see the first one is Knight c3
a lot of players just like to play
simple development move and not get into
any crazy lines or not familiar with if
this is the case you're still gonna be
taking here on e for taking the central
pawns is always key attacking the
Knights right here this would be
extremely awful if they played Knight to
g5 under attack and they say yeah I'm
just gonna go ahead and now double
attack right here my knight is safe just
because that losses to d5 now this is
solidified the central pawns we just
have so many threats on board we can now
push forward to this night right here
just not getting the material back that
they'd once black is not material
controlling the center White has nothing
for that loss and material they're
usually not gonna do that instead
they'll probably take here on e5 gets
that material back does have an outpost
here on e5 that's the case I would play
Knight f6 some of the reasons we've
talked about before making sure the
Queen doesn't come get involved into the
game now if they want to block off the
center or attack the center maybe d3 we
could play Bishop here before pinning
down the knight if it doesn't play his
pawn here you don't have to bring your
bishop but this is pinning down material
if they do decide to take we could
always play Queen to e7 yes we are
pinning down this Knight so we can
always take here and they can't
recapture with their knight but this
does that plus some we can now take with
our Knights here
once they recapture we can always
recapture with our Queen just gets more
pieces evolved into the game also
defends this Bishop here and before if
we ever
it too so this is also gonna be a pretty
good setup for black now instead of the
pond coming to d3 they could get their
bishop involved into the game Bishop to
c4 in the center and then this case
you're gonna continue with your plan of
pawn to d5 attacking the bishop you have
a pretty strong game from here the last
line I'm gonna go over is a pretty rare
line and it's someone that takes a look
at the counter gambit and says I see
your weird position and I raise you d4
first thing you need to go ahead and
shake their hand because achievement
unlocked this is your bucket list if you
haven't played this variation in chess I
mean what are you even doing you're not
even trying but from here I do have a
recommendation and there there's no real
move that's far beyond the other moves
but in that if that's the case I
typically tend to choose the move that
gives my opponent more options to make a
terrible move or make a mistake that is
gonna end up in me having a much better
game and that instant tends to be this
pawn takes on e4 same as before so you
don't have to think about too much
that's different here the reason is
sometimes if you play pawn takes on e4
they will say you're attacking my knight
I'm gonna go ahead and push forward with
d5 I have a defender with my Queen you
attack my knight I'm gonna go ahead and
attack your knight the problem is that's
gonna lose for white we're gonna take
their knight they're gonna take our
knight and then we're gonna play Queen
to h4 check now they may decide to push
forward with their pawn but then after
we play Queen to h5 we have some really
strong attacks here we have a discovered
attack with our pawn to f2 this is check
and a discovered attack on the Queen we
can get our bishop involved into the
game they don't really have that strong
of attack yes they can take our pawn
right here and check but we're just
gonna recapture with our Bishop they
have no follow-up items for that so with
that we are gonna have a extremely fun
game just chasing all the material
around just
King is wide open here to attack they
probably won't play that but definitely
some people may look at this they like
to get creative and say you attack my
knight I will attack your knight once we
take here you could see Knight to g5
also a terrible move but says yeah I'm
gonna go ahead and attack your pawn
right here maybe that's their go-to but
that's the case go ahead and take the
other central pawn the key in this
opening is to take their central pawns
now if they want to take our pawn here
on e4 great d5 attacking their knight
we're gonna have a very very good game
from here but the best move for them and
what you probably will see is that they
take with their nights here on e5 if
that's the case Knight to f6 we've kind
of gone through this before this defends
the pawn on e4 also just make sure
there's no shenanigans with the Queen
getting involved into the game so that
is the Adelaide counter gambit going
against the Kings gambit if you play
someone especially like myself that
plays the Kings gambit quite a bit this
is an opportunity to counter that with a
very fun counter gambit hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video this was a video
requested by someone that reached out to
me again the best way to reach out to me
is the chess website at gmail.com you
can always hit me up on Twitter as well
the the chess website and let me know
what future videos you would like me to
make but thank you guys so much for
watching and I'll see y'all in the next
video